I'm from Detroit a city that in the
1950s was the world's industrial giant
with the population of 1.8 million
people in a hundred and forty square
miles of land infrastructure used to
support this booming Midwestern urban
center and now today just a half a
century later Detroit is the poster
child for urban decay currently in
Detroit our population is under 700,000
of which eighty four percent are
african-american and due to decades of
disinvestment in capital flight from the
city into the suburbs there is a
scarcity in Detroit there is a scarcity
of retail more specifically fresh food
retail resulting in a city where 70% of
Detroiters robeast and overweight and
they struggle they struggle to access
nutritious food that they need that they
need to stay healthy that they need to
prevent premature illness and
diet-related diseases far too many
Detroiters live closer to a fast-food
restaurant or to a convenience store or
to a gas station where they have to shop
for food than they do a full-service
supermarket and this is not good news
about the city of Detroit but this is
the news and the story that Detroiters
intend to change no I'm going to take
that back this is the stories that
Detroiters are changing through urban
agriculture and food entrepreneurship
here's the thing because of Detroit's
recent history and now finds itself
with some very unique assets open land
being one of them experts say that the
entire cities of Boston San Francisco
and the borough of Manhattan will fit in
the land area of the city of Detroit
they further go on to say that 40 square
miles of the city is vacant that's a
quarter to a third of the city and with
that level of emptiness it creates a
landscape unlike any other big city so
Detroit has this open land fertile soil
proximity to water willing labor in a
desperate demand for healthy fresh food
all of this has created a people powered
grassroots movement of people in Detroit
who are transforming this city to what
was the capital of American industry
into an agrarian paradise you know I
think out of all the cities in the world
Detroit Michigan is best positioned to
serve as the world's urban exemplar of
food security and sustainable
development in Detroit we have over 1500
yes 1,500 gardens and farms located all
across the city today and these aren't
plots of land where we just growing
tomatoes and carrots either you
understand
urban agriculture in Detroit is all
about community because we grow together
so these spaces are spaces of
conviviality these spaces are places
where we're building social cohesion as
well as providing healthy fresh food to
our friends our families and our
neighbors come walk with me I want to
take you through a few Detroit
neighborhoods and I want you to see what
it looks like when you empower local
leadership and when you support
grassroots movements of folks who are
moving the needle in low-income
communities
and people of color our first stop
Oakland Avenue Farms
Oakland Avenue Farms is located in
Detroit's North End neighborhood Oakland
Avenue Farms is transforming into a five
acre landscape combining art
architecture sustainable Ecology's and
new market practices in the truest sense
of the word this is what agriculture
looks like in the city of Detroit I've
had the opportunity to work with Oakland
Avenue farms in hosting Detroit grown
and made farm-to-table dinners
these are dinners where we bring folks
onto the farm we give them plenty of
time and opportunity to meet and greet
and talk to the grower and then they're
taking on a farm tour and then
afterwards they're treated to a
farm-to-table meal prepared by a chef
who showcases all the produce on the
farm
right at the peak of its freshness we do
that we bring people onto the farm we
have folks sitting around the table
because we want to change people's
relationship to food we want them to
know exactly where their food comes from
that is grown on that farm that's on the
plate my second stop I'm gonna take you
on the west side of Detroit to the
brightmore neighborhood now brightmore
is a lower-income community in Detroit
there's about 13,000 residents and
Brightmoor they decided to take a block
by block by block strategy so within the
neighborhood of Brightmoor you'll find a
21 block micro neighborhood called
Brightmore farm way now what was a
notorious unsafe underserved community
has transformed into a welcoming
beautiful safe farm way lush wood parks
and gardens and farms and greenhouses
this tight-knit community also came
together recently and they purchased an
abandoned building an abandoned building
that was in disrepair and in foreclosure
and with the help of friends and
families and volunteers they were able
to take down the bulletproof glass they
were able to clean up the grounds and
they transform that
building into a community kitchen into a
cafe and to a storefront now the farmers
and the food artisans who live in
Brightmoor they have a place where they
can make and sell their product and the
people in the community have some place
where they can buy healthy fresh food
urban agriculture and this is my third
example can be used as a way to lift up
the business cooperative model the 1500
farms and Gardens I told you about
earlier keep growing Detroit is a
nonprofit organization that had a lot to
do with those farms they distribute it
last year 70,000 packets of seeds and a
quarter of a million transplants and as
a result of that last year five hundred
and fifty thousand pounds of produce was
grown in the city of Detroit
but aside from all of that they also
manage and operate a cooperative it's
called growing in Detroit it consists of
about 70 farmers small farmers they all
grow and they sail together they grow
fruits they grow vegetables they grow
flowers they grow herbs and healthy soil
free of chemicals pesticides fertilizers
genetically modified products healthy
food and when their product is sold all
over the city of Detroit and local
markets they get a hundred percent of
the proceeds from the sale in a city
like Detroit we're far too many far too
many african-americans are dying as a
result of diet related diseases
restaurants they have a huge role to
play in increasing healthy food access
in the city of Detroit culturally
appropriate restaurants inner detroit
vegan so yes we have a vegan soul food
restaurants in the city of Detroit yes
Detroit vegan soul is providing
Detroiters the opportunity to eat more
plant-based meals and they've received
an overwhelming response from Detroiters
Detroiters are hungry for culturally
appropriate fresh delicious food that's
why we built a nonprofit organization
called food lab Detroit to help small
neighborhood burgeoning food
entrepreneurs start and scale healthy
food businesses food lab provides these
entrepreneurs incubation hands-on
education workshops technical assistance
access to industry experts so that they
can grow in scale they're very small
businesses but last year they had a
combined revenue of over 7.5 million
dollars and they provided 252 jobs
listen
these are just a few examples on how you
expand opportunities so that everybody
can participate and prosper particularly
those who come from neighborhoods that
have been historically excluded from
these types of opportunities I know I
know my city is a long way from
succeeding we're still struggling and
I'm not gonna stand here on the stage
and tell you that all of the choice
problems and all of the choice
challenges are going to be solved
through urban agriculture I'm not going
to do that but I will tell you this
urban agriculture has Detroit thinking
about its city now in a different way a
city that can be both urban and rural
and yes I know these stories are small
these stories are neighborhood based
stories but these stories are powerful
they're powerful because I'm showing you
how we're creating a new society left
vacant and the places in the spaces that
was disintegration from the old they're
powerful stories because they're stories
about love the love that Detroiters have
for one another the love that we have
for our community the love that we have
for Mother Earth
but more importantly these stories are
stories on how devastation despair decay
never ever forgot the last word in the
city of Detroit when hundreds of
thousands of people left Detroit and
they left us for dead those who stayed
had hope they held on to hope they never
gave up they always kept fighting and
listen I know transforming a big city
like Detroit to one that is prosperous
one that's functional one less healthy
one less inclusive one that provides
opportunities for all I know it's tough
I know it's challenging I know it's hard
but I just believe that if we start
strengthening the social fabric of our
communities and if we kickstart economic
opportunities and our most vulnerable
neighborhoods it all starts with healthy
accessible delicious culturally
appropriate food thank you very much
[Applause]